GOOD MORNING THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY APRIL
TWENTY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. YOUR
VISOR AN AUDIO. AND THE
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEDURE
IS BEING MADE AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. THIS ORDER. THERE.
ALL THREE TELEVISED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC A TENNIS TURN MUST
WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES AND
COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE ABUSING ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATION OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA HERE
GIPSON HERE LATE YEAH LEVINE-
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS. RUBIO
VIEW PUTAH HERE WHERE A QUORUM
WE HAVE A QUORUM. IS NOTED FOR
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT HR TWENTY
ONE. THE CALL IN NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO- TO. AGAIN THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT HR
TWENTY ONE IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO-
TO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THESE
NUMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
WELL WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA-
SO THAT'S ME MISTER JERRY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
REFERRAL OF A CA ONE BE REMOVED
FROM CONSENT IS A ONE POTENTIAL
WOULD MAKE SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES
TO PROPOSITION THIRTEEN AND TAX
RELATED PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND
WITH WE BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
REFERRED ADDITIONALLY TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
THANK YOU ABOUT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN- I DO THAT. ONE OF ONE
MOMENT. EXPLANATION OF THE
REQUEST FOR REMOVING. AC ONE
FROM THE CONSENT- IS OUR MOTION
REMAIN THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVEMENT BY HOME I MISS THAT-
MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU MUCH
SAN ROMAN FOR LATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MOVED AND SECONDED-
MISTER SURFER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
BENNETT BENNETT HIGH FLOOR.
LARA AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE LEE
LEE HI LEVINE LEVINE HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I RAMOS. RAMOS I
RUBIO RUBIO FIVE YOU COULD WELL
BE APPROVED BY MOTION PASSES
OKAY THANK YOU ARE THAT MEASURE
THAT MOTIONS PASSED ON IS THERE
IS MOTION ON THE REFERRAL OF A
CA ONE. MOVERS FROM THE SENAE
BY MAYES RUBIO I'M A SUCKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM KNOW BENNETT. HI
FLORA FLOOR NO GIPSON GIPSON
HIGHLY THE I. LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS NO RAMOS RAMOS
HIGH RUBIO RUBIO HIGH YOU COULD
WELL BE APPROVED BY MOTION
PASSES THE MOTION PASSED ON AT
THIS TIME I'LL INVITE A
CINNAMON IS VERY IN- TO THE
PODIUM WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT HR TWENTY ONE. IN.
GOOD MORNING MY FRIEND IS ERIN
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
PREPARED TO DO SO. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. A COLLEAGUES I
STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY ASKING
YOU FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR H. R.
TWENTY ONE. WHICH COMMEMORATES
AND HONORS- THE THREE MILLION
VICTIMS. WHO WERE SYSTEMICALLY
KILLED AT THE HANDS OF THE
TURKISH OTTOMAN EMPIRE- THEN
THE REPUBLIC OF TURKEY- OF THE
THREE MILLION MORE THAN HALF
WERE ETHNIC ARMENIANS THE
REMAINDER WERE OTHER INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES WHETHER GREEKS
ASSYRIANS YEZIDIS. THANK YOU UP
FOR YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN
STATEMENTS OF DENIAL OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WHICH THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE HAVEN'T TOURED
SINCE. NINETEEN FIFTEEN.
SOMETHING MISTER RAMOS IS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THIS AND SO IS MR
LEVINE. UNTIL TODAY THE LEADERS
OF TURKEY DENYING THAT THE
GENOCIDE EVER TOOK PLACE AND
YOU WILL HEAR SUCH TESTIMONY IN
THIS ROOM SHORTLY. THEY
CONTINUE TO USE RHETORIC THAT
SUGGESTS THAT THEY ARE
UNWILLING TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PAST BY ATTEMPTING TO CONCEAL
THE TRUTH. PROPER RECOGNITION
OF GENOCIDE HELPS PREVENT
FUTURE GENOCIDES. SILENCE IN
THE FACE OF THE NILE EMBOLDENS
THOSE WHO WOULD COMMIT GENOCIDE
IN THE FUTURE. AND PROMOTES
IMPUNITY AND CULTURES OF
BIGOTRY. OFFENDERS OF
SUBSEQUENT CRIMES HAVE BEEN
EMBOLDENED BY THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY'S FAILURE TO CONFRONT
GENOCIDE. THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT
ONLY A MORAL OBLIGATION BUT IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO RECOGNIZE
AND TO MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
NAZARIAN ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK WITH A STRONG
STATE MEMBERS FROM THIS AREA OF
SEEN NO WITNESSES ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PROCEED TO
THE MIKE SIR.YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS KARA HAHN META AND THE
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA TO A CRUCIAL
ALLIANCE. PAGE AFTER PAGE PAGE
ARE TWO ONE TWO ONE CONTRADICTS
ITSELF. WITH FALSIFIED AND
FORGE INFORMATION. I WISH WE
HAD THE TIME TO RESPOND ALL THE
ALLEGATION ON THIS RESOLUTION.
RESOLUTION LIKE DOES THIS NOT
AIM TO PROVIDE YOU CORRECT
INFORMATION. IT HAS TO BE GOOD
ENOUGH FOR YOU BY MANIPULATING
YOUR EMOTIONS. TALKING ABOUT
THE FALSE INFORMATION. A FEW
YEARS AGO. MISTER NAZARIAN WENT
TO SO FAR INCLUDED TURKISH
CONSULATE NAME ON HIS BILL AS A
SUPPORTER OF ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
PLEASE ADDRESS THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE BILL OKAY ARMENIAN DIASPORA
PERPETUATE THIS HATE PROPAGANDA
TO BUILD NEGATIVE IMAGE FOR
COOKS UP BECAUSE OF THAT. MANY
TICKETS PEOPLE LOST THEIR JOB
INTIMIDATED HARASSED. THEY HAVE
NO LIMITS IT INTIMIDATION
INTIMIDATION AND HARASSMENT.
DID APPOINTED ME TO THE FBI. AS
A SLEEPER CELL TOWERS. AN FBI
TOURIST ASK ASK FORCE
INVESTIGATED ME. IT IS NOT A
FUN EXPERIENCE. IN LA.
HISTORIAN PROFESSOR STANFORD
SHAW- HARASSED AND INTIMIDATED
HE HAD TO QUIT HIS JOB.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE TURKISH
DIPLOMATS MAMMOTH VITA AND
BEHIND THE DEMO DIMINISH
MURDERED BY DO GOOD AGAIN YEAH
I THINK YEAH. AND TOOK MICHIANA
PARDON HIM. NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
TURKISH DIPLOMAT KEMMEL AKON
MURDERED BY SAYS SOUMYA.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM PREPARING TO
RELEASE HIM THE BOARD WHITE
FORTY TO FIFTY PER MONTH. MAN
AND WOMAN CHILDREN MURDERED IN
THE SAME PERIOD OF TIME. THE SO
CALLED SO CALLED ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE IS HOT COMMODITY
PROVIDE SOME ATTORNEYS
OPPORTUNITY TO PLUNDER ARMENIAN
CITIZEN TO MAKES MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WE ARE PLEASED TO
CONCLUDE REMARKS ARE SOME OF
THE ARMENIANS CHURCH. USE THAT
STRENGTH STAGE IN CONGREGATION.
POLITICIAN USE IT FOR GETTING
ELECTED GETTING APPOINTMENT
HIGH GOVERNMENT POSITION.
ARMENIAN DE ESPERA VICTIMIZING
BOTH TURKISH AND ARMENIAN
STUDENT FOR SELF INTEREST.
TURKS AND CITIZEN OF ARMENIA
HAVE NO PROBLEM. MY EX
GIRLFRIEND WAS ON AN ONION. I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPLAIN TO YOU.
BECAUSE THE CONSEQUENCES IF
WOULD YOU PLEASE BRING YOUR
TESTIFIED TO A CONCLUSION SIR
I'M SORRY I CONSENT WILL YOU
PLEASE BRING YOUR TESTIMONY TO
A CONCLUSION. WE HAVE FOUR
SESSION AT NINE. BUT THAT'S
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO I JUST
GET THE REALEST OF TREATMENTS
WHEN I WAS DOING IT I
APPRECIATE IT IF IT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE'LL GET TO
PLEASE RING UP TO A CONCLUSION
SIR. OKAY THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE
MEASURE. ON. LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR PLEASE
REMIND CALLERS HOW TO OPEN
THEIR LINES. MODERATOR. THANK
YOU WELL NUMBER OF THE PHONE
LINES MODERATE APPEARS WHY
CALLERS HAVE OPENED THEIR LINES.
ARE THERE ANY. THE GENTLEMAN
NOBODY HAS QUEUED UP SIR OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY KOURNIKOVA SHARE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS THERE AND I DON'T
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD TO IT HE ALSO-
WANT TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
HE- THE GREAT COUNTRY OF TURKEY
HACK CONTINUES THEIR GENOCIDE.
WITH- THE. SOME OF THE PEOPLE
I'VE FOUGHT WITH THE KURDS IN
IRAQ IN A CONTINUOUS- AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THIS BEHAVIOR AS NOT
BEING APPROPRIATE BECAUSE THEY
THEY FEEL AS THOUGH THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO GET AWAY WITH IT
WITH THE ARMENIANS WE SEE
CONTINUED WITH THE KURDISH AND
ANY OF THE STOCKS THEY NEED TO
BE RECOGNIZED AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR MEASURE- GOING FORWARD
AND- NOT BEING AFRAID TO CALL
THEM OUT FOR WHAT IS WRONG.
THANK YOU. RESTAURANTEURS ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS MR
LEVINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR- AUTHORING THIS RESOLUTION
IS ARE AND YOU KNOW THIS IS
BEEN- INTRODUCED AND PASSED IN
IN PREVIOUS SESSIONS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MARK OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE- I THINK
THAT- IT IS UNFORTUNATE. THAT
THERE WAS OPPOSITION PRESENTED
TODAY I THINK IT SHOWS A
FAILURE OF- PEOPLE'S CONFIDENCE
IN THEIR CULTURE WHEN THEY
CANNOT LOOK IN THE MIRROR AND
THE BAY CANNOT RECOGNIZE THE
EVILS OF THE WRONGS THAT HAVE
BEEN- PERPETRATED- IN AN
ANCESTRAL PLACE LIKE TURKEY
AND- AND I THINK THAT IF THERE
WAS A STRONGER GOVERNMENT IN
TURKEY- THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO WITHSTAND. HOLDING THAT
MAYOR UP TO THEIR OWN FACE AND
RECOGNIZING THEIR HISTORY SO
THANK YOU AGAIN THE COMMERCIAL
VAN AND THE OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- MISTER BENNETT. I
JUST VERY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
RESOLUTIONS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US FOR IT. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND OF MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
BENNETT BENNETT HI FLORA FLORA
I GIPSON ALL RIGHT GIPSON
HIGHLY. THE I. LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS I RAMOS
RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO I'D BE PUT
OFF. THE FOOD LIVE MOTION
PASSES. MOTIONS PASSED AND THIS
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU POLITICS THANK YOU.